I'm going to need to start looking for a place to live.
Good idea. You don't want to stay in that hotel the whole time you are here!
Do you know a good way to find an apartment to rent?
Well, I think the best thing to do is look at the rental ads in the newspapers.
Okay, I'll try that. Is there anything else?
Sure, you could visit a real estate agency.
Hmm. Well, I think I will start by looking in the newspapers.
Let me look with you. Maybe I can give you a hand. I know this city pretty well.
Okay, what should I be looking for?
Most of all, I think you should get a place that is in a nice neighborhood.
I also don't want to be too far from work.
Good point!